Donald Trump tweet stuff you know that
and the Treasury Department recently
retweeted one of his tweets the Treasury
Department does have a Twitter account
that tweet was allegedly illegal and
violated federal ethics laws and the
Treasury has now deleted that tweet or
retweet which you also maybe aren't
supposed to do because those do count as
federal government records which are not
supposed to be deleted so it's this
continuing and building comedy of errors
around Twitter Trump's tweet that
started this whole thing happened after
one of the Republican primary victories
special election victories recently and
Trump tweeted quote great Republican
election results last night so far we
have the team we want eight four nine in
special elections red wave that is the
tweet that the Treasury Department then
went and retweeted and immediately
ethics lawyer said wait a second this
violates the Hatch Act which doesn't
apply to the president it doesn't apply
to the vice president but it applies to
all other federal employees where they
may not tweet or retweet messages in
support of or opposition to a political
party candidate in a partisan race or a
partisan political group this one is
very clear the Treasury Department which
has the job of printing paper currency
and minting coins collecting taxes
through the power of the Internal
Revenue Service the Treasury is not an
organization that should be tweeting
about specific elections or candidates
or Republicans and a red wave in
November of 2018 so what did the
Treasury Department immediately do they
deleted the tweet and they're actually
going further they aren't even
explaining what happened they're saying
only the tweet was made in error the
retweet happened in error which is so
vague that it's completely meaningless
what does that mean does that mean that
someone meant to retweet that on their
personal account during their break but
they were still signed into the Treasury
Twitter account does that mean that
someone who was supposed to be doing
retweets on the behalf of the Treasury
retweeted the wrong thing they meant to
tweet a picture of Trump at the Treasury
Building and instead they retweeted the
thing about the red wave to say that it
was an error is so vague that it has
absolutely no meaning and we normally
normally if I came to you during an
administration I said you know that
retweet violated the Hatch Act most of
us would say I've never heard of the
Hatch Act what is that in this
administration we know what it is
because you'll remember that Kellyanne
Conway violated the Hatch Act when she
was promoting Ivanka Trump's clothing
line on I believe it was Fox and Friends
or Fox News
Sarah Huckabee Sanders has had run-ins
with the Hatch Act ambassador to the
United Nations nikki Haley countless
Trump staffers have had problems
adhering to the regulations of the Hatch
Act but the one similarity between all
of them is that there's gonna be no
punishment for anybody because that's
just how it goes this these days there
is no punishment there are no
repercussions unless we actually go and
vote them out so that's the retweet now
let's talk about deleting the retweet
there is something as you might know if
you watch the program called the
presidential Records Act PRA that
applies to the president okay and
increasingly we are seeing more and more
legal experts say that the president
deleting tweets which count as
statements by the president would be
illegal or would violate the
presidential Records Act which says the
president records related to statements
by the president can't be deleted
however this was the Treasury and not
the president so no concerns about
Records deletion right not exactly
because there's a similar sort of
equivalent law called the federal
Records Act which applies to others in
federal government and its agencies so
now let's do the micro to macro analysis
micro analysis does this man excuse me
does this matter it does it's the
continued flouting of all sorts of laws
and regulations by Trump and staffers no
penalties no consequences that is really
important let's now go macro the real
recent tragedy by the Treasury isn't
retweeting political garbage from Donald
Trump's Twitter account it's that they
changed the disclosure rules of
weeks ago so that nonprofits don't have
to disclose donor identities in more
situations which makes it easier lo and
behold for the NRA and other groups to
hide the source of dark money donating
to their organizations that is way worse
than retweeting something from Trump and
then deleting it because the retweet was
inappropriate that's the real corruption
that I want them held accountable for
Hatch Act violations okay
I'd look the other way if we were
seriously going after the total
corruption that is something like making
it easier for the NRA to hide dark money
sources and as always follow the thread
but remember which threads are being
discussed as a result and with the
Treasury there are at least a couple
here and those are the important ones
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman i love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the david pakman show I'm
sure you'll love politics and learning
and what blinka studs is take the best
and most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15 minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for just about
five bucks a month you can go to be li
NK is t-dot-com slash PA k ma n to sign
up